Transcriber: Reem Mohamed
المدقّق: Arwa Mohamed
يسأل الكثير أنفسهم هذا السؤال
دائمًا و بشكل يومي.
كيف يمكنني تحويل الأفكار،
التي في رأسي إلى حقيقة؟
كيف يمكنني أن أصل إلى الأحلام،
التي أطمح إليها؟
مرة أخرى، لما لست أنا من تبادر؟
محدثنا اليوم كان قادرًا على تجاوز كل هذه
الأسئلة و وصل إلى طموحات كبيرة.
من خلال نجاحاته استطاع نشر أجزاء
من سوريا إلى العالم الخارجي .
نفس الوقت جذب انتباه العالم العربي والغربي
في آن واحد على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
رحبوا معي بالشاب المهندس مؤسس
منصة ماي سيريا، أيمن محمد الرفاعي .
مساء الخير، أنا ايمن محمد الرفاعي
عمري خمسة و عشرين سنة.
أخبروني، أنه أنا اليوم
أصغر متحدث مشارك معكم.
الصراحة هذا الموضوع أخافني،
لكن في نفس الوقت حفزني.
جعلني أفكر في ما الذي يمكن أن أقدمه
و كيف يمكن أن تكونوا مستمتعين معنا.
أعتقد أنكم الآن تسألون أنفسكم،
لماذا عنوان حديثنا اسمه “لماذا ليس أنا“.
حتى أستطيع الرد عليكم،
يجب أن نعود قليلاً بالوقت إلى 2013.
كان عمري بهذا الوقت خمسة عشر عاما.
بهذا الوقت مع بداية انتشار الفيسبوك
و السوشيال ميديا في منطقتنا،
قررت  أن أنشئ صفحة على السوشيال ميديا
باسم هنا دمشق .
أعتقد الكثير منكم لا يعرف هذه القصة
وهذه أول مرة أحكيها.
في هذه الفترة حاولت تقديم
صورة عن الشام أراها بعيوني.
بالرغم أن وقتها كانت الإمكانيات قليلة
من  الهواتف، التي كانت معنا
أو حتى من المواد المصورة
لدمشق على السوشيال ميديا.
لكني أعتقد، في فترة قليلة
استطعت تحقيق جزء من حلمي
و وصلت إلى انتشار معقول جداً بهذه الفترة.
لكن للأسف لم أستطع اكمالها؛
لأنه كان لدي شهادة  الصف التاسع.
لكن أكيد حلمي لم يتوقف عند هذا.
الآن سنعود إلى عام 2017.
بهذه الفترة كان هناك موضوعين يزعجوني جداً،
الموضوع الأول هو الصورة النمطية
للغرب عن سوريا،
التي يتم ربطها بالصحراء و الخيام
و أننا بلد لا حضاري .
الصورة الثانية لها علاقة بالحرب مع سوريا.
للأسف ارتبطت سوريا فورًا بالدم والخراب .
حقيقة أزعجني هذا الموضوع جداً.
وكنت اسأل نفسي،
لماذا لا يوجد منصات على السوشل ميديا
في تلك الفترة أظهرت الصورة
الجميلة عن سوريا.
و هنا سألت نفسي لأول مرة،
لما ليس أنا من يقوم بعمل
منصة تحكي عن سوريا؛
حتى أستطيع أن اري العالم،
كيف أرى سوريا بعيوني.
هنا في خريف عام 2017 استطعت عمل منصة على
الفيس بوك وانستغرام اسمها ماي ذا ماسكس.
في وقتها كان هدفي بسيط و هو فقط،
أن اري العالم كيف أرى الشام بعيوني.
حتى في وقتها الحقيقة لم تكن
الإمكانيات قوية بدرجة كبيرة.
لم يكن لدي ما أصور به غير هاتفي.
حتى في هذه الفترة كنت الفتى الوحيد
لأهلي بين خمسة بنات،
هذا الأمر جعلني ملتزم مع أهلي
أن أكون بأماكن محددة بدمشق.
أماكن استطيع الذهاب إليها كثيرًا بالشام؛
حتى يمكنني تصويرها لكي تروها،
لكني استطعت و أنا جالس في غرفتي
مع هاتفي عمل هذه المنصة.
بعد سنة بدأت ماي ذا ماسكس تصبح معروفة أكثر
و بدأ العالم يعرفها
و بدأت توصل لشهرة معقولة.
وهنا قررنا نتوسع و نصل إلى حلب؛
حتى نقوم بعمل منصة أسمها ماي أليبو
وبدأنا و هدفنا كان في هذه الفترة،
أننا نقوم بعمل منصات لكل مدينة في سوريا؛
حتى يرى العالم كله هذه المدن كم هي جميلة.
لكن في عام 2020 أتتنا فكرة،
لما لا نقوم نحن بعمل منصة
واحدة تشمل كل سوريا؟
هنا يكون تركيزنا موحد بمكان واحد
و نكون قادرين على عمل محتوى مناسب لها.
و هنا بدأنا، لكن في هذه الفترة كلنا نعرف،
أن كورونا بدأت.
أزمة عالمية يخاف العالم كله منها
يخافون من شيء مجهول.
جلوس الناس في الحجر و في بيوتها
أصابها بالضيق والملل.
هنا لم نشعر بالملل ، الحقيقة.
هنا عملنا على محتوى ماي سيريا.
بدأنا بوضع محتوى خاص بنا و أفكار
جديدة و نصل لفئة كبيرة من العالم.
و الحقيقة في ربيع و خريف هذه الفترة
تمكنا من عمل انتشار معقول جداًً
قدرنا نوصل لكثير من الناس
في سوريا و خارج سوريا.
و هذا كان صعب جداً بالنسبة لنا.
الآن تذكرت بداياتي، كان لدي أصدقاء
مقربين مني
أتذكر بوقتها كانوا يقولون لي،
أيمن ماذا تريد في هذه القصة؟
تسلى بموضوع آخر
هل ستستطيع تغيير العالم؟
في وقتها أعتقد لو كان إيماني وشغفي ضعيف،
كنت سمعت كلامهم و تركت وما عملت هذا الأمر.
لكنني أخذت هذا الكلام بإيجابية،
أخذته حافز لي؛
حتى كل مرة أكون تعبان أو مضغوط بسبب معين
يقويني هذا الكلام.
أن هناك حافز، يجعلني أقوم بما أحلم به.
و الحقيقة كان حافز مهم جداً.
نفس هؤلاء الأشخاص هم الآن أكبر الداعمين لي
و هم يشكرونني جداً على الأمر الذي قمنا به
و أنهم ينتظرون منا دائماً كل شيء جديد.
اليوم  نعرف كلنا “الميديا“، كم هي مهمة
في العالم و في سوريا.
كلنا نعرف أننا يمكننا استغلالها في
شيء ايجابي و شيء سلبي.
هنا سألت نفسي للمرة الثانية،
لما ليس أنا من يقوم باستغلال هذه الميديا
بشكل إيجابي لأجل سوريا.
وهنا بدأنا نلقي الضوء على سوريا
من الناحية الجمالية و الثقافية
و التراثية بتراثها المادي و اللامادي
و التاريخ و السياحة
وحتى نلقي الضوء على نجاح
السوريين من كل العالم لكل العالم.
والحمد لله نحاول القيام بهذا،
طالما نستطيع فعل هذا الأمر.
و هنا الحقيقة بعد كل هذه الفترة
أصبح لدينا مسؤولية كبيرة جداً.
اليوم ماي سيريا قدرت توصل
لعدد كبير جداً من العالم،
ملايين أو حتى عشرات الملايين من
المتابعين على السوشيال ميديا.
هذا الأمر أعطاني مسؤولية بشكل خاص،
أن أكون متأكد من أي معلومة
ممكن يتم نشرها عنا
و من أي محتوى ممكن يُنشر،
و أعتقد هذه المسؤولية تخطتني أنا كفرد،
هي صارت مسؤولية كل السوريين،
أننا حقًا نستطيع تقديم محتوى
يليق باسم سوريا،
محتوى نقدر نفتخر به في أي مكان في العالم.
والحمد لله نحن اليوم قدرنا نوصل لأكثر
من خمسة وسبعين دولة حول العالم،
تحب سوريا و تتابعها
و تعرف أخبارها من خلالنا .
الآن أقول، ماذا أفضل من أن يربط
الإنسان يربط شغفه بدراسته؟
هنا أيضاً سألت نفسي السؤال للمرة الثالثة،
لما ليس أنا من يقدر أن
يربط  شغفه بدراسته؟
هنا ربطت شغفي للاستكشاف و التوثيق
بدراستي للهندسة المعمارية.
قبل شهرين بالضبط كنت أقف مثل
هذه الوقفة على قاعة جامعتي
و أقدم مشروع تخرجي.
في وقتها قمت بتحدي نفسي،
أن أقدم مشروع مرتبط بذاكرتنا لدمشق وسوريا.
مشروعي كان بعنوان “إعادة تأهيل محور
سوق الصالحية وحديقة عرنوس“.
هنا عاهدت نفسي أنني في المستقبل
سوف أخذ مشاريع
لها علاقة بإعادة تأهيل و تطوير وتجميل
المناطق، التي تهمنا كدمشقيين و كسوريين.
و أتمنى من كل المهندسين،
أن يأخذوا هذه الخطوة؛
حتى نقدر نقدم تصور بسيط يليق باسم سوريا
حضارةً وبالسوريين.
أيضًا
ماذا يوجد أفضل من أننا حقًا نقدر نقدم
هذا المحتوى بهدف سامي و نبيل و هو سوريا؟
أتمنى حقًا أن تكون هذه المهمة ليست
مهمتنا كأفراد وحدنا، بل تكون مهمة جماعية؛
حتى نقدر جميعنا نقدم هذه الصورة.
في الختام أريد أن أقول لكم، ثقوا بأحلامكم
و حققوها ولا تردوا على أحد.
أنا إذا رديت من خمس سنين على كلام أصدقائي،
لم أكن لأتواجد معكم اليوم
كأصغر متحدث في تيد كس.
لم أكن لأحقق جزء مهم من أحلامي
وأنا متأكد بعد فترة قليلة سأكون
قادر على تحقيق أحلامي أكثر.
لهذا أتمنى أن نحقق جميعنا هذه الأحلام.
الآن هذا  فيديو سوف نراه
كان إهداء مني الى مدينة
دمشق بمناسبة مشروع تخرجي
لنراه سويًا ثم نعود.
إلى دمشق أقدم أيقونة مأهولة في قلبي،
المدينة التي ولدتني وعشت
بها على قدر ما عاش أبي.
فأعطتني الكثير و أعطيتها ما استطعت.
بتواضع زهرية نبتت في حديقتي أو في ديار؛
رغبةً منها في أن تزيدها جمالاً.
قبل أن أودعكم أريد أن أقول لكم على
مبدأ أنا أتخذه ،
كل سوري هو سفير بلده في المكان
الذي هو متواجد فيه و يعيش و يشتغل به.
ماذا يوجد أفضل من
أننا نكون اليوم حقًا خير سفراء لسوريا؟
أريد أن أشكر فريق ماي سيريا،
الذي هم حقاً أعظم سفراء تعرفت عليهم،
الذي هم متواجدون في
سوريا و كثير من دول العالم.
أريد أن أشكركم جميعًا
و شكرا.